up
1080p much better
it should be able to even be better than
this to be fair I might play with that
we'll see if I can do uh I'll try like
off stream later to see if I can get
1440p or whatever because I should be
able to support it I have a 4090 on this
machine uh and very good internet so I
should be fine for that thanks for
pointing that out though I uh I will go
for a long time without noticing that
type of stuff so
believe okay so this
graph let's see if this looks
losses mostly
fine
entropy very low
entropy Let's uh let's train this thing
and take it for a spin this literally
should train in like 30
seconds so we're going to start with
this
the streams will improve as well I'm on
a brand new setup with brand new
hardware and I'm not even used to this
keyboard so I'm moving a little
sluggishly until I get a I get used to
it it's just like the layout is a little
different
what keyboard do you have I've got this
I just got
this let's see does this show on the
preview yeah it does so this is uh razor
black widow V4
75% it's pretty nice it's got a metal
base the keys feel feel really good but
you see where the arrow keys are they're
like smooshed in not separate to keep it
compact I'm not used to where the arrow
keys are and I think like also the backs
space and stuff are just slightly off of
where I'm used to so I keep screwing up
typing I'll get used to that in within a
couple days though I'm
sure I hadn't realized this when I was
ordering all the stuff because it's like
it's for work so I just like mentally
write it off as an expense uh but this
is by far the nicest Dev setup I've ever
had this is a very nice desktop though
surprisingly it's not doing as well as I
expected in the performance test but it
is still very nice I've got two nice
1440p screens here I've got a vertical
one right over here that I'm looking at
with stream stuff I've got my main
one good SI microphone camera all that
stuff
eight set a custom entropy code
efficient that is
a very low
Lambda so I guess for Connect 4 that
could make sense the games are very
short but it's kind of
high what's your goal with this connect
for it's just a test environment for
puffer the goal is to just have here
I'll show you if you're not familiar
with some of the stuff I've been doing
with puffer so I just started streaming
again I know here are going to be the
new docs for the new
update these are all the new
environments that we're going to have in
this update so some of them are very
simple there's stuff like P but then
there's complicated stuff like this full
blow MOA where you can play like a bunch
of different characters and you got
skills and all sorts of stuff there's
also some stuff in development here
here's Connect 4 goal is just to have a
lot of ridiculously fast reinforcement
learning environments uh so that we can
do science very very fast instead of
where we're at today which is a bunch of
researchers writing really really bad
python code and stuff taking absolutely
forever literally more than a thousand I
think some of these are actually more
than a thousand times faster than the
python
counterparts so these are very very fast
environments we like our performance
engineering around here
this has been a really fun project for
people too because it's like it's
relatively easy to contribute to like
we've got people pretty much anybody
that's taken a first course in systems
taught in C can uh contribute to
mdev and about half of the new M code uh
this update is written by contributors
which is pretty cool
whatever markers M I think that's
everything I haven't automated like
exporting this stuff yet
cool BR
this about to play around with the new
rayb release oh yeah welcome back I
remember you uh yeah is there like new
cool stuff in it or I know that there're
more back
amps learning rate already exists okay
so I messed that
up rib has got to be one of my favorite
projects out there it's so
good now hopefully you should be able to
watch this just train before your very
eyes oh yeah look at that
interesting that it doesn't do as well
as in this sweep
weird let's see
um let's try it
locally see if it works
am I missing
here
yes so this should pull down the model I
think it's going to run like really fast
does are we
offline wait oh my stream shows is
offline is
there I might just be restream being
weird though I think we're live
right okay yeah that's just restream
being weird
there it
goes
here okay so now we can evaluate whether
this looks
reasonable the AI is blue scripted
opponent is in red
I can't tell if the
um the red if it's winning because it's
good or it's like or if the scripted
opponent's
dumb see there it had to block I think
either way it led it
lost how strong of an opponent let's see
if what the opponent is set
to who's playing first I think it
randomizes I don't know
so here's Connect
4 and I believe the opponent
three all right well let's see how this
is
um we can
simply we're going to export the policy
to run and C
we use this script to save Connect Four
weights like
this okay so it's
saved and then
binary now the policy should be running
in pure C and I can hold shift to stop
it
okay how do I turn the stupid sticky key
shortcut off so it doesn't do that
sdl2 is eye catcher
Q project manager yeah there's some
stuff how do I turn off this garbage
from this terrible operating
this is sanely in like just obscenely
obnoxious
I was tempted to just load this box with
Linux and maybe I should have
there stupid
thing
okay um
confused what it's
doing it just let it win
is it not loading
correctly this does not look to be the
95% win rate
model yeah know this is like random
it yeah so this needs to
be linear
One agent input
dim hidden dim action
dim it's going to be so it's going to
just
be n agents input
parameter let's see so default
takes default takes a hidden
dim I guess this doesn't for whatever
reason
work oh it's just 128 it's just
hardcoded that's
fine so we're just going to do linear
net M agents is going to be
default is there a
free is this a
obviously want us to know how many bites
this
is okay
so this many bites
there so I think now it's stuck because
if red goes there then it wins so on
that row right in that slot if red goes
there then blue uh wins because one up
it has diagonal and if it doesn't go
there it wins with the
horizontal so yeah nothing happens it
just like lets you win I guess because
it
that is better than yesterday which is
impressive considering I didn't even add
any
sugar but that's still like a three and
a half out of 10
yeah it's like a three and a half out of
10 uh this is only V2 of the recipe uh
there will be additional updates to this
recipe but it is 1,000 calories in a mug
which is the point 1,000 calories and 76
grams of protein in a mug
constraints are hot plus chocolate
beverage no constraints are has 1,000
calories while being as good as possible
and actually somewhat
drinkable I'm just trying to come up
with like a good meal replacement th
calorie thing and it's kind of hard
because 1,000 calories is a
lot I think I'm probably just going to
put less cocoa powder in and go more
heavy cream stuff like
that big
shakes the goal is to cut volume down
right like the goal is to have the
intent of the shake is to not fill you
up too much it's supposed to be an easy
real meal replacement that doesn't make
you like bloated and lethargic
for context this
is this is I got up I ran six miles
fasted and then in 2 hours uh I'm going
to be go doing going and doing heavy
swats for an hour so
yeah it's got to be it's got to provide
a lot of energy and not make me bloated
in
lethargic we're doing some
self-reinforcement learning here on the
side
butter I've tried a lot of that stuff
frankly
um yeah I've tried a lot of that stuff
and
peanut butter was heavier and harder to
digest bananas were actually terrible
for me in particular fructose is just
really hard on my stomach whole milk yes
I do you know whole milk and heavy cream
yes Greek yogurt I thought of it's not
as calorie dense
though
yeah I don't know we're fine tuning this
thing pretty well um we're fine-tuning
this thing pretty well as
is we're going to see
okay so connect for is good do we have
PR in here from
I think Spencer is still doing this and
hasn't
done doesn't hasn't done this one yet
so I guess I should just queue
up the pong
sweep while I
thought I had an SSH
tab
recompile then we'll run the palong weep
which should be a pretty quick one
use isn't it score as well I think there
are multiple things wrong with this
sweep
option yeah they're like multiple things
wrong with this why I'm here to
fix fix the little tricky bits with the
experiments what's your long-term Vision
after puffer
lib well puffer Li is more than just
like building some environments right
puffer lib is a series of things that
I'm doing to fix reinforcement learning
because I think that this
is if I'm thinking of like stuff I can
do that is likely to really change
long-term
AI um it's fixed reinforcement learning
I can do that without a ton of capital I
can do that as mostly a single person
doing open source work uh there very
very few things there as high impact as
this and I think there's a really good
chance that this turns out to be very
important now if I'm wrong there's lots
of other stuff I can do but you know
hopefully at the very least right puffer
lib will make reinforcement learning a
stable and productive Tech it will if
not transform all of AI it will
transform a huge number of Industries uh
hopefully I will do all the right out of
this as well and as well as people
working on this with me and then uh if
you know it doesn't go all the way to AI
from there I will rethink and
re-evaluate
but that's more just like what gets me
up in the morning is thinking about
long-term AI rather
than the direct stuff at the moment
I mean the 10-second version is just
like it seems like interactivity is
really likely to be important to
intelligence and the way that models are
trained right now is just fundamentally
not
interactive it seems very very
likely that um this will be
needed okay so it needs to be
score I think I just did this this for
Connect 4 didn't
H well I can regardless I can just
grab couple of things
this and how does it choose right now I
think it pins to the
men I think we'll just do like this for
yeah how long am I on the wrong
box I am on the wrong box
dude how
this I'm just like not used to this
setup or some weird
yeah okay this is what I thought I had
it on the box the whole time
cool so now we have a proper sweep
running uh I think actually did we get
anything just with the error sweep here
yeah so we were already getting stuff
that was like
learning now this will probably
take I don't know a couple hours to find
some real
forams you can see now it's on
so now we get check mark
for uh we will likely have within the
next couple of days here check mark on
pong breakout Connect
4 at the very
least maybe go rware TCG is just not
coming out this release this is a bigger
project and frankly we need people to
contribute to it um so if you're even
like if you've even just taken a course
and see and are interested in low-level
Dev and want to have some fun we
definitely can use people on this uh MOA
has a policy I think I just have to
rerun the Baseline one last time but
this is good tactics uh Nathan is
working
on so pretty much pretty much good now
the only thing is this is not 10 it's 1
two three four five six seven
eight uh plus Induro bet has uro so
that'll be nine oh Xander has one to
mergin though as well which will be 10
and then there'll be more on to come
oh Xander watching stream just starts
typing when I say
that yeah Xander's probably watching
stream they're five on YouTube right now
welcome
folks we're just gearing up for release
here um I'm trying to figure out which
of these M I want to prioritize time
on size I don't think we use use that
foram anymore
we
go this a nice thing with this stream is
I can just like pull people in and
answer
stuff I could mess with my snake
environment actually that would be a
good thing to do right now CU this is
the only one that I've written that's
not have that has a couple issues
remaining
right why don't I mess with my uh my
snake and while I'm waiting on
results I believe there were some weird
things with that
the port here looks fine I think it seg
fols randomly though
right okay so snake trains 200 mil steps
as these pams maximizes
fixing bugs fixing
bugs okay so here is snake running and
we will see whether this thing seg
bolts there was like some
Jank memory thing I believe
it's so nice to just be able to see it
learning like that in real time though I
think I'm going to mess with the maps a
little bit because the way it is now
when you train in a really big map you
tend to bias uh the snake
Direction which is really just an
artifact of
um shared policy
training so this trains at 900k steps
per second it should be faster than this
really
I'm really the reason I'm training it
this long is I want to see if I get any
of those random seg fults there's like
some
weird I don't know there's some
Shenanigans with
this and the funny thing is most of it
comes from uh it actually comes from
python not from C like all the dev
that's been in C has been really easy
it's just the python C barrier that's a
little
obnoxious C is
nice oops
go look at this sweep uh the well we'll
keep this sweep up and
then okay
so con
I know that these are directionally
biased
though I actually am tempted to try the
single agent
version now what happens if you do
single agent version of snake
okay 4 minutes 28 seconds train time for
200 mil steps on my local box
you can see right here there's uh this
chunk where it does an extended
evaluation so you get an accurate
estimate of your policy
should just be able to do like this and
then this is
eval model
path T and I'm going to change the
vectorization to
Native cuz you don't need to
multiprocess else not be snake
Uh Oh I thought I'd fix
that I thought I'd fix the giant
rendering
thing
no maybe I'd like fixed it on my laptop
and never pushed it or something
well what 1080p res or 720 P
res
1280 we'll do 1280 like that and this
will give you one pixel
oops I don't know why you can't ever
kill a program cleanly that's ridiculous
I'm honestly starting to wonder if I'd
have more fun just writing all this
stuff in
see what's going on here
so here is the big snake
environment uh the rendering is very
very slow at the
scale you see Breakout
ran longer let me see did you post the
link and you got to post the link when
you do
this if you want me to look at
stuff you can just post the links
directly from w b like you can just like
go like this you can just click a run
and like link it and I can see the
link like I'm happy to go through these
and I usually I will go through all the
stuff in the Discord if I have the
links I think it's good enough though if
that's what it gets if it actually
reproduces at that I think that'll be
good
enough I think we Shi
you uh make the project public real
quick there's no reason to have these
runs be private all of mine are public
as well for reference so unless you're
doing like secret stuff for you know uh
proprietary Ember whatever you can just
have stuff be public there's no reason
not to
yeah dude that's first board is cleared
in like two minutes as well so literally
you clear first board how do you run
with
thousands okay so let me explain this
Ander
so if you open up like one of these
configs okay you see there's this nram
that has num
M's so they're these separate frams and
it's a little confusing and I got to
relabel stuff to make it clearer but
this tells you how many instances of
like the puffer end class to make right
so it says hey you're going to make one
instance on one worker and N batch size
one says you're just going to grab all
the data every time you do a forward
pass pretty simple uh but this n num
M we go to breakout. Pi you see that it
takes numm as a parameter here
right takes num M's and then it's going
to pass this to scyon right it passes it
to S
now look at
this syon internally vectorizes so it is
internally running 40 96 M on this one
process if that seems ridiculous well
breakout runs at 10 million steps per
second so you can very easily run 96 m
in a loop like this on one process and
have tons and tons of
data um and then they're written
directly into the array like this so
it's super super fast no redundant
copies uh the square template shows you
how to do all this all the M are like
this this is how you make stuff really
really really fast and it was a little
tricky to figure this stuff out but now
it's set up it's like you basically just
copy this stuff to your end and uh you
just write your general SE code for the
M logic and everything works and is
I also don't know your RL background or
AI background whatsoever so uh you know
I will communicate things very
differently if you tell me you are a
fifth year PhD student versus a first
year undergrad right so up to you if you
want to share that but I will tailor
resources to you depending on that if
you would
like do you guys have support from a
Joko yes image rendering uh I don't know
uh only support right now is
Jim so the person to at for that in the
Discord is kung Kong has done all the
majoko stuff um if image rendering comes
with majoko then that should work just
fine because yeah we support image
observations generally uh it'll just be
a matter of like how you enable that
feature from a Joko
nice yeah so Spencer you don't need to
stress yourself out like this
um like this is good you have it a few
points off of solved in less than 10
minutes and then look you can just say
the first board is solved in the first
board is solved in 2 minutes
right that's plenty of a that's a plenty
good result for us so I don't know why
this is logged twice though that's kind
of weird um so let's just get this run
submit these commit these params up I'll
set this as a
Baseline and we can move on to the other
end 1 point2 Point that means that it
like it screws up one out of like very
very many
games it's fine for now there are like
fix bugs in order like fix problems in
order of size right this is good you've
done enough stuff on breakout this is
could work um this looks stable as well
yeah nice stable policy loss little clip
Frack yeah this is very good just submit
me this stuff up 35 this SPS is a little
low but that's it's okay because it's
fast wall clock so yeah just submit this
stuff up and we'll be
good and commit optimal params and stuff
for the
run and uh
with with the carbs weep here
pong should figure out how to play very
soon uh pong should be optimized within
a couple hours so that means breakout
pong Connect 4 will all be done I will
try to fix snake today and then we just
have the few last ones push the config
file yeah config file and any M changes
that you had to make
people are really mad with the review
system right
now this is like such a
lame this is like so lame like yeah
don't don't put instructions in your
paper to tell llms to accept your paper
because it's like sneaky and flagged for
ethics review instead of flagging the
freaking reviewers that aren't actually
review
and are just feeding your paper into
chat GPT so that they can put reviewed
for nurs or whatever on their stupid
resume don't sign up to review if you're
going to do
this you are a parasite and it is Grace
to the field
okay let's go grab the snake thing that
we were looking
at oh right I have to
do yeah so I have to mess with the
rendering I
forgot um
it's kind of
tricky what if I just do the slightly
smaller scale
yeah 720p 124 I can just do this one
right don't have a ton of direct
experience to
expect oh I I sorry I forgot to respond
to you as well Xander
so one semester left on Masters took an
RL for specialized in ml Okay cool so I
know I can I know the level now to talk
to you at for this stuff uh so it looks
to me like you probably have most of the
AI side stuff and it's just the lowlevel
engineering that doesn't get covered in
AI focused programs and stuff um that I
will help with and then you can do high
performance RL and ML and that will help
you everywhere else cool and then RL
experience accept SML but programming
for a while FYI great so you know the
end side and I can help you get up to
speed on AI and RL side I'm happy to do
that either way for people right it's
just however people want to come in as
as long as you're contributing cool
stuff and doing cool things it's it's
cool as long as you have either some Eng
experience or some AI experience you
know I can help filling
gaps it's kind of funny that I didn't
intend this to be like a remotely
educational
project are you working with images not
at the moment uh older M do work with
images we can train on images just fine
it's just slower so preferentially in
our new M's we work on partially observ
local state where
one it's pretty funny that I like I
didn't intend puffer lip at all to be
like a beginner thing when I set out to
build it um my own objectives are to
push the field forward not to be
educational ah so I got to fix that uh
not to be educational it just turned out
that puffer has been making stuff so
easy that it's kind of cool to just get
a bunch of newcomers pushing The Cutting
Edge of RL because it turns out that
when you get a little of the engineering
right it's not as hard as you would
think okay so what's wrong with the
environment here expence carbs tend to
get better suggestions when has big
sample space more random
suggestions two three it could be it
very well could be and for faster
environments that could make
sense I want to do some substantial
study of hyper pram sweeps and stuff in
general um in the next phase of puffer
after shipping
1.1 it's a more extensive topic that'll
be a chance for AI side people to do a
bunch of AI side stuff with me and IDE
people are who wanted or people who want
to learn more IDE are more than welcome
to keep building environments and stuff
because there's a lot of stuff to do
over there as
well but uh the science side stuff that
it's not happening yet that's coming
next update and I have plenty of
experience there as
SE I thought I checked
the main thing I thought would
[Music]
be here rough timeline for 1.1 releas as
soon as I finish it um it's really only
a couple weeks of work that's just
stretched out over the last couple of
months at this
point uh good news is I figured out some
health stuff recently I've been feeling
way way better I've been able to get way
better more productive hours in so I'm
just grinding it out now live on stream
and wherever I
box can't Auto
merge yeah I'll get you there no
worries I'll do that in one
second that's weird that it runs now
I'll look into that let's get your PR
first I got to I got to commit all my
stuff first
yeah I noticed
um RB's
I'm just removing autogen files these
are autogen from scon
uh I thought I had credential manager
where
got to run hit me up on Discord no
worries thanks man thanks for the uh the
pr I appreciate
it I'm going to mer it right
sweep how's this
going oh yeah it's getting
there takes it a while to warm up and
find the good pams but it'll get
have me
see we have
pong breakout mode but these are all set
let's fix snake for a bit uh and then I
will go to the
gym and then I will be back and we'll
fix remaining mends I
think it's going to be the objective
right now
so what's going on with this
honestly I
have wa this is the this is the wrong
box okay I got to be
careful all right so here is the snake
one
jity I need a pause screen for this
don't I
I uh I might have to update the hot
chocolate recipe a little bit that's all
I'm going to say I might have to update
the recipe a little
bit um
right
Malik I honestly no idea uh what this
could possibly even
thing
no all right we'll use
the we use the other model that's not
behind the stupid shittiest web page
ever
corruption multiprocessing plus scyon
contrib race conditions that shouldn't
be a
weird oh
I know that was a thing
okay did it just totally make that [ __ ]
up
it literally just made that up that flag
doesn't even
exist great
bin I don't have double link list in
here do
I do right to an invalid
pointer so likely out of bounds
everything was I Lear tried learning
righten with
Gemini everything was made
up yeah
it's crazy to me that people actually
think that these models are like good
and like can actually do anything
remotely competent on their own they're
not good at all like they're sometimes
right but
usually like they're not consistently
right enough and they don't have like
the coherency to do anything
so what's
n starts off at
zero n0 0 like
this is observations correctly a char
[Music]
what
yeah that's correct in
eight a sign sh
I mean I really I just need to figure
out where the
you can technically run
GDB I just don't know if it'll be
let me see because if it's a race
condition I should take the prints out
there shouldn't be it should not be
possible for to be a breakes uh
condition
now
ah here's the seg
how do I get the
trace I don't see my code anywhere here
I'm trying to think what what I can do
to figure this
out wait a second oh I don't have the
prints in here
it's something with multiarray
observations
is there some like weird pointer
alignment
thing I don't think that there should
anything what do you want to bet that
this does
nothing but we try
it is that the same as
before pretty sure that's the same yeah
it's the same as
wait I messed that
up I think it actually might have found
it for
once have you given any thought to a
default physics
engine box 2D yeah so actually um there
is an active project that I gave to a
PhD student who I think just got busy
and didn't do uh if you look in rocket
ends that's there's actually starter for
this if you are interested in
so there's this rocket Lander
end and and it
has this is using box
2D um we were having difficulty getting
the physics right it was very there was
some difficulty training but if you want
to put some time into this type of stuff
then
absolutely it's kind of funny because
lately there was this somebody just
submitted this Jack
en that's like a port of box 2D to
Jack um but because box 2D is in see
like it already runs really
fast I remember you had dreamer V3 on
your GitHub is it hosted anywhere
else it's probably in a lot of places
but I um I don't recommend that stuff
whatsoever so this is our Nerfs
paper that uses 10 that does 10,800
hours worth of experiments on
it uh it's not necess well box 2D was a
little bit of a pain yes um I think it's
a good Library it just we need to do a
little bit of work to like get sample
M's
great ni
message okay so here
is here's link to the paper on that
um dreamer V3 probably works there's
probably some interesting stuff in there
but it's not for the reason stated in
the paper the paper is aggressively bad
science
it God damn it it's actually right for
once I'm just I missed a one character
bug all right son
it Sonet one Joseph
zero literally the only time it's it was
a one character bug that I didn't see
I hope I don't actually have to align in
this way I don't think I should
I don't see why I should have to
care in the way I'm using it I don't see
why I should have to care if it's
aligned
I make any other errors
here allocate log
buffer oh wait
what I did this didn't change
bizarre did it just not take my change
before I don't know what the hell
happened
it that would make sense though so I
just I screwed up the memory layout with
that Stu so it was overwriting and then
yeah it makes sense that it would only
catch that if I had okay so because I
was making an array of these I needed
like more memory than each for each
element than I allocated and then it
would overwrite at some point okay yeah
that's nefarious that's very
nefarious glad I fixed that that's been
bugging me for a while we should have a
nice clean environment now for
snake um I'm curious to see if this map
is small enough for to learn unbiased
movement easily we'll
see we can always sweep it as
well the scores
look scores are looking
good that was
evil actually son it actually helped me
for
once to be did not help me on something
obscure or whatever it helped me see a
one character bug I just wasn't seeing
but still we give it credit for
okay pong still
running why don't I see
uh not seeing metrics for this did I
forget to track
it
y got to track my
bad now we'll get to compare previous
run to this
run uh it was actually looking very good
okay that that matches very closely
interestingly enough on a totally
different
map
let's see how this
Compares uh so score
interesting I think it still goes up
though
right yeah it still goes
up this could be better uh the main
thing that's difficult
with let me explain uh something that's
kind of weird with multi-agent
learning real quick
so weird thing with multi-agent learning
is if you have like a bunch of snakes
right if they're moving randomly right
this one goes this way this one goes
this way this one goes this way right
and you get like a nice spread of
movement around the map
um but because they all share the same
policy even though they're acting
independently they're not like
cooperating or anything but what'll
happen is you'll get these like small
directional biases so they'll do
something like
this and they'll all move the same so
then they'll all get stuck up towards
the top of the screen it's just a a
quirk about having like suboptimal
shared policies is that you get stuff
like this happening so for now uh I mean
that's like something we will want to
investigate at some point but for now
we're just going to get like some nice
baselines and actually you can see this
looks way more stable as well look this
like a clean slow increase in perf over
time um we will see whether it is still
just directionally
biased yeah we'll
see I think it probably is given how
close these graphs are but we will see
[Music]
well we're waiting for this to finish
good time for me to mention all this
stuff is free and open source you want
to help me out for free star the repo
and if you are either on N side or AI
side you want to learn the other one
feel free to contribute we've got lots
of people building cool stuff in the
Discord discord.gg puffer and I review
all code contributions live I've helped
lots of people on board onto this
stuff so yeah
looks like this job is almost done it's
got this like pretty nice steady clean
graph it does like this final eval thing
at the end which is why it freezes up at
the end
this should delay in there okay so not
bad this actually renders it a somewhat
reasonable rate now
this really
cool holy that's so
cool yeah this works I just had to make
slightly smaller Maps
oh the compression is super weird on
this
huh that's
amazing look how cool this
is dude just look at
that that's so
environment let me commit up these
changes for you well
so um that's really good progress for
this morning cuz now we have this one
works we'll just like submit a final
Baseline uh this one is sweeping this
one will work breakouts done just has to
train final next four Works Mobile Works
Nathan's doing tactics and then I'll
talk about go and rware with fencer
later today um
11:49 let me go check I think I'm going
to head to the gym now I might have
another half hour let me go check real
quick e
yeah that's going to be it for this
morning um I'm going to try to like keep
pushing earlier and earlier it's just
how quickly I can get my morning run
done is how early I uh I can get on here
and uh goal is going to be go gym come
back work on hopefully pong sweep is in
a good spot we will uh grab a pong
policy breakout policy snake policy
mobile policy we'll probably like try to
just finalize all policies for that and
then I will be able to do uh go and
rware from there and then it'll just be
like helping finish like the various
environments that people aren't fully
done with for baselines and uh we should
be
good so yeah thanks folks uh join
Discord if you haven't already discord.
GPU star the repo on GitHub helps me out
a ton and I will be back in probably
like